the other set of less important
extensions is I've been double the
triple angle results okay so one of the
one of the results this one I think the
bottom of the first side of the sheet is
4 10 3 theta so how do you work out 110
through here is it just terms of regular
tans okay it's not a particularly fun
press as some of you might have seen me
do it yesterday you just want to treat
it as a regular expansion of theta and
Jupiter okay and it's gonna become a
little bit gross because these two are
gonna expand out into fractions again
watch what happens if I used to treat
this is my a and my B okay on the top of
the tan a plus B expansion is 10 a plus
B and then on the denominator 1 minus
the product which is okay and I work
with this thing I'm gonna have to expand
again okay now I'm just gonna finish
this out because this sum draws out a
lesson for us the expansion here is
double equal to 10 all about 1 minus
one - two data and same thing multiplied
okay now just to make my working simpler
I don't recommend that you do this
though if you're trying to solve a
question and it just feels like it's
taking forever like say a trig identity
okay you can do this just to save
yourself a bit of time but maybe not
present here and so like this everything
here is tense okay so I'm just gonna say
about 10 feet up and each will say
capital T it's just gonna be faster for
me to write that's all okay so I've got
T plus 2t on one - to sweat all over 1
minus T outside of the same thing okay
so what should I do to this fraction to
simplify the little I want to get rid of
these fractions on fraction probably
right that's the easiest way to go so
I'm gonna multiply everything top and
bottom by 1 minus T squared that will
eliminate my passions you see that what
are you changing the fractions at all so
T times that is t minus T cubed this
times a fraction eliminates the
denominator on the bottom I'm gonna have
a 1 minus T squared there this here
let's see what happens you've got 2 T
squared times 1 minus sorry that just
cancelled for my fraction
come up here all I need to do is just
kinda like terms so that's equal to 3t
minus T cubed and on the bottom here
about T Squared's that go together 1
minus 3t squared and this just speaks
that up in terms of what it actually
means so here is the triple angle
identity or tan okay now again just like
with the half angle ones you don't have
to memorize because it's not that useful
right typical example have a look at the
second side of the sheet number images
but there's a question which has a
triple angle and if you see it it's like
tan squared yeah yeah that's right
N squared 3 alpha is equal to 1/3 right
okay
now having proved this you might think
oh well I'm intrigued expansions so I
better you just I forgot to make I
should use my trig expansions for for
this question right so if I give that a
go what's gonna happen well I've got
what is my 310 be no - tang cubed all
over 1 minus 3/8 and squared and that's
squared and that's equal to 1/3 right do
you like hmm well it's all squared right
I guess that means has 9 tan squared
theta minus 6 10 for theta plus 10 16
all over one minus 6 tens with either
plus what's that's the stream out of
your ears because your brain is melting
okay this is solvable but you would
probably be dead by the end of it ok so
what should you do instead triple angle
is about the best way to purchase
instead you should rewind and say well
okay I'm gonna stole this right but
fulle look alpha but for 300 it's a how
does it work if that's my domain for
alpha then my domain for 3 alpha will be
multiplied by three right so me 1080
okay how does this affect us as we go on
I'm just gonna keep on watching through
without worried about what the app this
will be they'll come out later so if I
take the square root I've got minus 1/3
okay so that's gonna be 30 degrees
that's a base angle since I hustle - I
need all the quadrants yes so 3 alpha
will be 30 degrees the next one is 180
minus 30 degrees the next one is 180 +
30 degrees the next one is 360 - now
this point you reduces stop except where
in terms of 3 alpha and your domain
keeps on going way past 360 right so I
shouldn't just get my regular for
answers this to me they made is three
times larger social I should expect
three times as many answers okay now
relax even though you like far out so
many it's very easy to get what they are
because just four B's plus 360 plus
and then I have to add 720 to get to the
next law right so let's see okay 12
ounces because that's how long my domain
is but then of course I actually went
out long so just to buy everything my
710 you can keep going from here right
so I'm gonna have all 12 of my answers
but that was I mean it looks terrible
but you were gonna get those top answers
anyway if you solve that off Windows
believe me earlier right at least this
okay so this is why Triple A the results
usually when they appear there's better
ways to deal with them triple angle
doesn't tend to actually make things
much better it makes it worse okay so
that's why should have memorized
rippling results okay I mean sometimes
LM here just to show that you can go
through solving a trig identity but you
wouldn't actually use them to solve the
questions